welcome to your mom's house this is a
very exciting weekend there's a lot to
talk about but of course we have some
business to attend to Jean I am going to
gonna I'm going to dive in together I'm
going to be in Richmond Virginia first
show was sold out July 11th we added a
Late Show few tickets left for that
Virginia Beach the next day sold out
Greensboro
has a few tickets left Asheville North
Carolina sold out Charleston South
Carolina on July 15th not sold out
plenty of tickets so many tickets ok
from there I go to Montreal Hampton and
Canadia Canadian yep
Wilmington Delaware and balls and whores
Maryland oh then optimum straya we do
have to know I have a ton of fall dates
they're all on sale Tom Segura dot-com /
tour please go ahead and check those out
we do have to announce that
unfortunately due to unforeseen
circumstances the mom cast that we had
planned July 9th
we're not able to do it that day show
these guys it's show business we are
honoring every ticket sold at the
October 8th Irvine Show so computer
you're in sperm vine if you want to go
to that show we're doing the podcast
live 10 8 October 8 your tickets that
you had for July 9th are good on our
code
rate if you're not available to come to
that you can get a full refund so
there's no problem with that we're also
doing the podcast live August 23rd in
Brest Falls Beach
that's the West Palm Beach improv in
Florida investable so make sure you
check that out
gain anything else no I'm taking a break
now for a while after shooting a special
let's get into that after that make
Niraj after the uh yeah after the break
here yeah because there's a lot to go
over with I'm just doing that's deep bro
doing your mom's house so check out that
Z bro if you haven't already I talked
about some real-life shit you know Sam
Wow talk some shit please go to your
mom's house podcast comm shop through
the amazon banner any amazon shopping
you were going to do if you do it
through our banner it gets a little kick
back to the show and it greatly helps
the show so if you like our show and you
can do it there's a Canadian banner and
a UK banner as well as the regular u.s.
banner and it's very you know it's very
helpful here we go Junior Eddie to start
the show super ready bro do it G file of
a South Florida man accused of killing
his girlfriend continue today and so far
no ruling on if we'll be able to show
his penis to the jury
like he requested for more on the sale
of the defense call the Suarez he said
following video a phone Fort Lauderdale
Carlos my auntie don't bring anyone love
into this no more motherfucker welco
welcome to your mom's house
with Tom Segura Christina
[Music]
yeah Fort Lauderdale for a louder Dale
fart louder Dale seaman hole yeah cock
it comes come see no rock cock and come
see no and art louder Dale I think that
was one of the first cities we started
to make fun on though because I was like
such a the hard cock come see no it was
right there the hard cock company no it
was right there those reporters were
super attractive it's South Florida that
was that why yeah of course my Miami
adjacent yeah yeah attractive people of
course seriously Miami Miami la Jude or
titties good-looking people yeah on the
news especially God and this is a Latin
vibe so they got to be sex I mean oh
you've never seen a female anchor
anywhere that looks like right right no
pegs allowed no not in Fort Lauderdale
and the weather girls usually have like
those Oh cut on down there why is that
Tom I think the Latins demanded y todo
porque yo man algo que no se hey XE no
way Y what is it with the Latins in the
sexy what is that
Miami sex culture is crazy I remember
talking to guys now who you know are
adults now about middle school in there
like you know we're fucking in fifth
grade and it's my favorite by the way
are you talking about who was fuckin in
till the kid specifically who
specifically kids wind of children what
do you mean like who all the kids or
that's what he was he was saying that
one of my friends was saying that that
you'd be made fun of you know like
that's what you'd be teased about like
oh you have been fucking yet like 10 11
years old I had I think but you know you
see the footage from carnival in Brazil
oh my god you know titties out ass out
it's also it's less thought of as taboo
you know not they're just like I had
people of sex keep I think it's a little
hyper hyper sexual yeah but still
they're not making it this dangerous but
the actors but be also the irony is is
that they're deeply Catholic so then you
have
ironic this weird juxtaposition is like
hyper sexual and then hyper cast line
and they love their mothers a very
maternal cultures like you want to fuck
or do you want to fucking feel guilty or
do you want to fuck your mom see it
looks like your mom and I'll remember
when we were in Puerto Rico yeah my holy
grail and I felt like I was visiting the
Wailing Wall
you know what I mean for me it was just
that personal to finally go to Puerto
Rico
of course remember the towel
they would sell beach towels that were
just like naked boners just naked people
aren't like painted no sexual Sharona
yeah what's that babe what who's your
owner
yo know that player yeah learn what your
Ross smells like put your cock and balls
smell like but not sexual it's not
sexual not much not at all that's about
sexual guys let's just pop a bunch of
guys just hanging out just hanging yeah
being real being guys that's so funny
see Aussie Stern blockers were pretty
sexual too but we keep it no like they
make out in public like the kids so
that's because everyone lives with their
parents I remember RT semester abroad in
Spain was a lot you saw a lot I mean I
was in Madrid a lot of MIT like a public
teenage make outs a lot yeah it was it
was overwhelming but oddly enough like
when I was in Peru which is South
America Latin culture very Catholic they
were much more like they were obviously
doing things but it wasn't a public
thing you put on a public face of a
little more reserved
well decorum yeah yeah man you know come
on hold it together Pig but I mean
that's Peru and then right over here
resilience totally different but it was
just like they just fucking the streets
in Brazil right I don't know if they
fucking the streets but they definitely
there as is that they let their asses
out and our titties out everywhere dude
you go to South Beach
you see those tissues everywhere yeah
that's right all kinds of today I kind
of like just like the gays but I like
that culture I feel comfortable in that
it makes I feel sorry comfortable right
yeah all Latin cultures yeah me too very
familiar I like it I like it too I you
know my own tribe makes me a little
uncomfortable
by the way same to me yes
they're supposed to Eastern bloggers
it's all about making you feel not
welcome
I feel like uncomfortable it's just
harder their heart more hardcore also
this whole thing about showing emotion
is bad see yeah it's wasn't weakness
overly emotional thing can be
overwhelming I hope emotional people and
your crew but the one thing that's nice
is you always know where someone's
standing you know yessing when you read
someone yeah so like with what what's
common among like latin people is like
you know when they're upset you know
when they're happy
you know when they like something you
know when they're excited yeah and then
that's this coldness thing where you go
like does the person not like me or does
the person upset and they're like no
that's just normal but that's that takes
a lot of getting used to because they're
not giving you a clear signal yeah see I
actually I view it the opposite because
in Latin culture sometimes they're so
polite that they don't tell you like for
me I have to be hit over the head
because I grew up that way they just
tell you like you're a fucking piece of
shit and you that's how you communicate
I'm actually used to more over the head
formal communication
yeah if we were talking today like our
nanny is very Latin and didn't like she
doesn't come out sometimes we have to
kind of she can't hide it that's right
right right she won't I've seen that
show she's very she'll satisfy you yeah
but she will not 100% hide how she feels
yeah yeah
if you go do you mind saying later today
she'll go sure it's so obvious at that
point that she doesn't want to she go
jeb plans after well you're like okay so
then do that don't worry like I could
adjust my thing you hope to stay late
okay okay she's so sweet but that really
wouldn't go like no I have something to
do yeah and my family would be go fuck
yourself I have to do some things you're
intruding in my life you're ruining my
life
she's so sweet we have a housekeeper
that we've had for years - she's from
she's Cuban and last week she was here
cleaning and there's been an evolution
in her phone game yeah look at first it
was like occasionally she'd be on her
phone cleaning the house
Cawood you get because you're like I
yeah you're doing like busy you know you
don't need to think a whole you know
it's busy work essentially like you have
to think but not it's not focus and then
it involved her like the Bluetooth right
like was narrow
oh no no should use the earpiece it's
the earpiece I evolved to like if I walk
in the room I'd never say anything my
office ring which is on the phone I
would hear her in Spanish obviously
they're like oh I gotta go even the
implication was the you know be my
employee I'm half a is here right so I'm
gonna end this nonsense right now right
now if I walk in the room and she's on
the song should be like yeah yeah anyway
and like I talk louder like yeah guys
yeah fucking here but anyway so later on
if you guys want to get together and
like come yeah completely disregarding
my mind it highly in music so do I have
no actually I know God she does a great
job it does interfere with the work look
she get to talk to her friends why not
but now it's evolved to she just puts
them on speakerphone and then puts the
phone on the counter so now we hear both
sides of the conversation in Spanish
which is fine too it is funny though cuz
you'll be like wait who's talking oh
it's dark leaning leaning on the phone
with somebody again and she's always
like I know that was always her with I
think I know I think abut a little
better why she did did she say that oh
yeah no I'm a really interesting accent
Cubans
I like how she'd speak Spanish it's cool
I heard her one time you hear speak
Spanish you hear
nanny sick Spanish and here my monastic
Spanish and you really have them say
specific sentences you will hear it just
like you're hearing an American Brit and
like a Scottish person that's crazy
it's all dialects but they understand
each other notice it's the same language
but their accents and their slang is
100% different right yeah just like
America just like just like the gate
it's just like the gate um nothing I say
no I remember
mmm thanks well how about this we have
kind of a celebratory thing going on
right now you shot your first special
I'm so exhausted and I'm so happy and
I'm so grateful we didn't tell anybody
but you came I came up there and you
opened for me I know that was so fun and
it was the best surprise ever to the
audience and they freaked out and people
really seemed to enjoy it the jeans were
one pair I'm so glad you came with me
Gina so thankful cuz I mean I was always
planning on going what four months and
you know just going to be your your
support and you know just make sure
everything's going well you have what
you need and then a few weeks ago you
were just like I think you was you he
said like would you open and I was like
yeah of course it ever occurred to me
can we think about who you know
offer it or anything but ended up being
very really fun it was super fun and I'm
so glad you were there just that I
didn't freak out day of the guy I didn't
freak out I freaked out three months ago
you know when you know it oh shit
there's a there's a date now like
there's a Monken thing and then day of I
could sleep the night before I was fine
but then I felt myself around 2 p.m.
getting in hair makeup that's when like
the terror started occasion I was glad
you were there just to have somebody I
to talk to that spoke my language
interesting perspective guiding day yeah
tell them that I was really close to
someone but I'm not the one doing it
where you're seeing the day evolved but
you don't feel the pressure of doing the
show the pressure on you it's all for
you and that's a brother and then I know
I understand why now the managers and
the producers are like great do your
thing because that's exactly what it
felt like yeah big deal yeah we walked
over there I was like people day Dania
looks great just do your fucking show
what's your problem yeah that's not that
big video what's your problem
right take your pronoun get out there
and be paulien by and the thing is it
really isn't in the end of the day
because we've done it for so many years
and you once or once I got up there it
was like oh this is my second home but
let it go down
but the lobby it's it's a little
overwhelming when you walk in and
there's this whole thing and they're all
for you it's all freezers many cameras
there's screams there's producers
there's people are talking to you a
person crew and yes yeah it's not a is
not your friend being like hey do you
free this afternoon
there's a lot of money and a lot of
people's livelihoods essentially here's
the thing that's so crazy that the
reason that there is Mary and the reason
why you'll always have some form of
anxiety on a shoe days you just never
know how it's going to go yeah and then
afterwards like luckily for you I can
tell you that like man it's got to feel
good because it went so well it's
amazing and you know don't like and you
know it's captured you know it's like
yeah when you shoot these things you you
could be on tour I'll tell you the first
one I did was in Minneapolis I'm sorry
where many apple tits okay
and I know people will say you know oh
are you trying to be dramatic
this of the hundred and fifty shows
leading up to that taping in Minneapolis
that was the worst show of the hundred
and fifty talked about your taping day
was the worst show of this of all the
shows knowing up to it no yeah I swear
to you like the audience was just shit
yes god damn it yes it was terrible and
this is completely normal
yes oh my god which ended up being like
special special everyone loves and but
that's how I find the other lesson for
that for me was that was because it was
well received by some people you know at
home yeah you realize that even with
what I experienced ultimately you're
performing for the people at home yes
it's a television there were jokes that
fell so flat that I used to getting such
a big laugh on there was it was just
like it was one of those things where
you're like you know I go you know I was
like well this is just what it is yeah
but but you have I live in South Florida
man accused of killing his girlfriend
continued today and so far no ruling on
if we'll be able to show his penis I
kind of glad we got to see a man
although Suarez's of following this
Carlos Torres are do that's a Latin name
yeah but I wanted to say that ultimately
you know you have the the best part of
it which is the people are going to
enjoy their home but people in the
audience loved it yeah it was it was fun
it was really it was a really I was I
was really here's the thing it took me
14 years to get here amazing and I'm
kind of glad it took
that long because I think had I done
this we were talking about this this
morning had I done this even five years
ago three years ago I would have been
shitting in my pants yeah so I think it
took like it took it took longer and I'm
glad it did I'm thankful for it because
it gave me the time to calm the fuck
down
and just like enjoyment and enjoy the
day I was actually more sad about about
it being over you know you're like oh
now I don't have that thing to look
forward to learn more like that's kind
of gone well I'll tell you guys one
funny thing that happened during the
taping so halfway through the first show
you know they get out and they tell you
guys hey don't don't get up and take
away yes falling out because we're
taping and it interferes with the
cameras blah blah so halfway through my
set and maybe less quarter when I hear
some nasty motherfucker got up and was
flushing the toilet and you can hear it
in the showroom and I was like I got a
hold for sound like I can't just tell my
joke through toilet flushing but it
ended up being like this crazy moment
and I'm like who is shitting in the
middle of my oh so funny
flushing flushing and flushing like it
was so perfect for for your mom's house
essentially for people to be there and
someone taking a shit in my show like
immediately it's also like that's all
there's two ways things can go in a show
something happens and your instinct can
be to get upset this is ruining the
moment
right right right go try to make it
funny roll into that you rolled with it
thank you
and it'll be interesting to see whether
you keep it in and I now if I William
you'll see it in the in the line cut and
you'll see whether or not you want it in
but it was in to experience it from
where I was and to see you keep going
with it was really funny well I don't
know if you know this I mean I don't
mean to be talking out of turn here but
I am the queen of improv oh yeah I don't
mind you saying it yeah yeah yeah that's
really you were very your improv skills
were really good there well I'm really
um I'm really thankful to have you there
the best part of it seriously was having
you there and knowing that the mommies
were in the audience supporting me and
laughing and that was so special I think
it's always special when it's you me and
the mommies I just love it it was I
really do love it we really have
it really was a fun fun night yeah
special very special my cousin Julie
came down she and her husband live in
Washington now so it was good to see her
too and you know yeah a special very
cool I look great I love my outfit my
jeans were high super tight are you
gonna wear jeans on your next taping
course I've always one dream I know I
wear jeans under my under the dress that
I were you want to go back to this news
thing I would love to go back to this
news so obviously you just you heard the
clip of the jury or they haven't decided
whether this ending can show his penis
to the jury yeah the associate medical
examiner of rhoward County took the
stand about an hour ago and said that in
all his years of work he has never had a
single case where some would choke to
death as a result of performing oral sex
so his testimony goes to the heart of
the defense's case that Richard
Patterson did not kill his girlfriend
back in 2015 prosecutors alleged that
the 65 year old to the death but he
claims as she choked on his penis
the Emmy told jurors a penis would have
to be large far enough down a person's
throat to block that person from
breathing through their nose and a mouth
he also said that it would take two to
three minutes for a person to die as a
result of a lack of oxygen that it would
have been a cure that Nickerson this
woman had a toddler he wasn't distressed
he wants to show the jury is painted how
did I get asked to be like yeah you can
chose on this yeah here's the medical
examiner and if she can what booth she
usually stops making yeah or to do
something it's my tribal this bloke in
the books every way try to open this
Airways it's normal reaction of any
person so he's saying she should be
flailing and biting and you know
flipping out because she can't breathe
right I mean here's the thing as someone
that has done this before done what
nothing I kiss PBS before that you kind
of know when you can't breathe so why
wouldn't you just put your mouth get
your mouth away from it so he must have
choked her well he was probably pushing
her head down or so
make my ass make my ass yeah my friend
rock oh yeah
alright now the defense has asked a
judge whether Patterson can show jurors
his penis as part of their case clone is
not meant on whether that will be
allowed to take place
yeah ethical examiner also told jurors
that he could not rule on a matter of
death because the body of 60 year old
Francisco Martinez was in such bad shape
when he was found inside her Moorgate
home well interest that hangs what
though that it's sat around for a long
time in bad shape I don't know she's hot
though right the Jezza now for our
listeners could you describe the
defendant I mean they don't know there's
yeah he's old as dad I mean he's got red
skin all white why hair like Santa
without a beard yeah I mean you won't
even expect this guy has a dick anymore
ya know I let it get hard think it's big
enough to choke me yeah I doubt that
he's real similar to the premise of Tod
Shaw aka to shorts on blowjob Betty
right and was she busted nut and killed
a bitch but that's from the nut I know
that's what yeah yeah but it is similar
in the premise they both their dicks
both were involved in murder that's
interesting what a neat point I wish you
would bring that up to the judge yep the
medical examiner is still on the stand
and the defense says that spelled
otherwise did not call nine one on the
night that I wanted to happen because he
was embarrassed about the whole thing so
whenever one know something
why not guilty he was found not guilty
serious like yeah not guilty I think he
choked her I did I did too on a key a
super big peepee how could you choke
yourself on someone's dick that's a dupe
'add he killed her I should rethink that
she waited yep what fuck how old is this
guy he was 65 at the time so now he's 67
he nasty to him he's so nasty with your
big old dick you big old stinky dick you
know I found out she finally pulled from
from the episode my parents run yeah I
vibe excited
yeah I did with POTUS I go retarded
I go return it I go retarded I did with
pleasure that's interesting NRT picked
retarded yeah sure at home everyone
everyone yeah I didn't realize how
popular a choice that would be you know
personally I would take the sexual abuse
from my granddad but you know because
then you can just go to therapy and deal
with that but you can't treat retarded
you can't really treat it but some
people really hate the other option I
guess yes man for my dad it was just
agent food all right let me think of how
much you have to write that yeah that's
just like I love Korea barbecue and I
love sushi
can't imagine I mean obviously I would
just be like an agency forever yeah all
day every day I love it and that's one
of my favorite cuisines of the world
what could you eat every day
mmm I know steak I do love me yeah and
that's very good
yeah I could eat that a lot you have
sushi the other day and I gave you
diarrhea instead I cannot learn beg no
more now you just keep eating at
America's eating and shitting everywhere
I just I just did you know it's fun
that's why I get my name snake from boy
because I'm afraid of no party you know
what's so funny yesterday we flew home
on Bergen yeah and our fright attended
her name was Debbie I was so stupid we
were like you're wearing maybe whatever
yeah she's really nice that was nice
what did you say by the way the driver
to the airport was like and you're
flying a Virginia Airlines Virginia I go
virgin he goes okay hey don't you do
this drive all the time who's flying
Virginia air weirdo he cleared it wasn't
like a little slip-up he was Virginia
air today even a thank you cross that
many deaf people fly the Virginia from
here so weird yeah so she was Debbie and
I was like hey you're see that movie
Debbie Does Dallas and she goes no you
know it's out and it's just
are you gonna do everybody on the plane
she's like I think so
where you gonna start front to back hey
I got started back I guess that's quite
a job
yeah could you imagine if that was your
college eyes when I lent you I'm sorry
to get to do everybody I just try to do
everyone but I couldn't that's a chair
okay so what if that's your job maybe
that's a good would you rather I mean
ask at all be nasty it's all but it
really is all mental it's can you remove
yourself yeah yeah it's can you remove
yourself from the horror of doing all
these people or can you like separate
yourself like a like your you know think
of yourself like a kidnap victim or
something you know would you rather be
debbie the flight attendant who has to
do the entire plane who or Saigon that
old guy's wiener wait and potentially
die or can I back off of I'm joking know
that the potential for death is there
there but you gotta just like it once
for a hidden thing but people are saying
out I know they're going dude obviously
be heard you have to suck that guy's
dick but on the plane they're my guys
there's 80 guys yeah yes I eighty dick
right yes I'm saying that's like that
all good for sure I was like that old
guy's dick to overdoing the whole plane
you have any nasty like there were so
ugly people on that Magnum a he might
kill little ding-dong
now by that I would know when I was
choking and then I thought of you and he
probably held on and that's how she died
he too old fuckin could you imagine
blowing just a random plane of people
you might gross people are on airplanes
there was fat ones skinny ones greasy
ones smelling ones I was on a plane last
week where this kid was taking a shit in
first class we were real later was a
teenage boy and anyway the guy was in
there for 20 minutes the flight
attendant is knocking on knocking on the
door finally he gets out it's a teenage
asian kid he's fat take a big shit and
it stank's so bad that the guy in front
of me refused to go in and take a piss I
was like you got a kidney and then this
whole this hippie kid pushed his way in
front of me
I let him go in he's like what what's
going on why is everybody standing
around I'm like why are you letting me
go you'll find out and he's like I see
why now let's go parallel mouths
horrendous one time I got on a plane and
a dude shit and we came out Nate was
stuck
no inside of the toilet so I hit flush
and the water just went over it yeah so
bad and I told the flight attendant she
was on I got some and she just had a
purse affray and her person just did
like 20 sprays in there I was like man I
can help yeah I go it's just it's just
me putting perfume on that shit is all
you're doing you know yeah it's like
good so gnarly
ma'am here we go email you to talk about
a hair removal between the cheeks and
have discussed waxing I'm here to tell
you a much easier and less invasive
method to remove all that Brown
collecting first Nair god I'm good
old-fashioned glass that shit on up in
your cheek now while minding the more
sensitive skin that is the ball soccer
vulva within a couple of minutes wipe it
off with a washcloth in the shower it
gets into every book and brown cranny
and Webster where the hair without
having to be humiliated by having an
actual person wax your asshole I have
much experience with this and no bad
reactions
I hope this has provided you with a much
to the solution to main mother Tina's
version aka excuse to not devouring your
asshole Tommy love you both and
Christina is the life champ okay I like
that life champ Caroline that's a lady
right thanks Caroline Caroline i am i
have used near on my legs and it is a
very volatile chemical substance yeah it
smells really bad and strong so she's
right you gotta be real careful about it
touching your your kibbles and bits so
if you put on your asshole I mean I
don't know how she does it she must have
a lot of experience because that is
trick I'll try it it really will burn
yeah go to her if you get it on your
tender through tender zones yeah yeah
it's real let's hold them up for a
little bit I want you to leave it on for
several minutes yeah it's quite narrow
like burned the hair off that I think
how it works like a chemical burn mudra
is printing
our Leandro hey you gotta get your teeth
whitened before I know you do your stuff
you look you're telling me online
they're commenting on how yellow your
teeth are no your teeth would do I
should we're going to shoot something um
here we go ah this guy when he worked at
Ball fart they made us do a chant in our
meetings oh my god we had those last
week and they were just all for our wall
yeah because uh God shabooya shabooya I
think about you know it's Shibuya was so
horrible that I think about it every now
and then I'll be like in our closet and
I'll say poor people okay oh my god
[Applause]
meaning I know especially for like you
know it's not a job that you love no
nobody's like a career Walmart employee
it's a stepping stone place he said that
when they were I mean in a sales level
not I mean management took place in the
middle of the store in front of cut like
this give me a w w en a hey give me you
know
ow and he said squiggly we had to go up
and down shaking our butts give me an M
and give me an a hey you know our aren't
give me a tea hey what's that spell
Walmart
I can't hear you Walmart what do we want
say people money how do we do it so they
can live better right away sorry
so money save money live better whoo
guys that was my life for two years oh
my did have more personality than mommy
through - shit Travis well Travis I
liked you until that last line yeah
that's okay so let's go there would you
rather work at Walmart and have to do
that every morning that is so depressing
or why oh my god I would I would be
broke broken spirited for Cecil in there
but then there's other I've had this job
before where you call people and you
solicit them to buy tickets to things or
to take surveys so what I rather
do the sales pitch or I go retarded yeah
okay now it's Walmart you do that or you
have to go door-to-door and get people
to like save the whales or donate money
to the children but you're going
door-to-door I would rather do that and
you have to do the pitch of like hi
ma'am can I speak to you for just five
minutes you have a moment
I know talked about the high injection
and the time well I can't do so hard a
cheering the cheering - amazing I'd
rather do the cheering honestly it's so
hard to go door-to-door and get rejected
I mean I've done I've done the call
center stuff I should have harder labor
hi ma'am aha can I just take five
minutes of your time like I did with
POTUS doing a survey on eggs you know
did you know that eggs have lower
cholesterol if you really say that I
could yeah the X survey was my first job
when I was 14
horrible horrible Jesus but the fucking
you know what it is I can't feign I
can't feign team spirit that that's the
soul-crushing part it's like that you
really give a shit about Walmart I know
of course that's the worst part they
can't think that you do so the top top
brass here or multi-billionaires am i
right
come to w how much am I making twelve
now all right mm-hmm drinking healthcare
no I'm just the CEOs okay sweet man yeah
terrible it does sound fun good shit
John
you're a fat count again Mike bloody
disgraceful will tell you that for Bart
yes somebody said it in you no good
cross shot you're a fat count again Mike
bloodied is frightful what the word on
the street and I'm not I don't know if
this is true so I don't want to talk out
of work at a turn whatever but and word
on the street is that he's gained his
weight back is that is that accurate
it's pretty bad yeah I mean everyone I
meet I'm gonna stand up there like
Bert's fat again every time I go there
like he was here last night they're like
he's a whale Wow yeah he's super
enormous he did just post a really funny
video do you see it called Code Red Hulk
Hogan
I got hope it isn't I love Hulk oh and I
was really funny so you know that his
wife the hall didn't the Hulk's wife
leave him for like one of their
daughters friends like a 20 year old
away stories
God how would you murder me if I did
that because they were together for a
long time Hulk and Linda really just
obviously when I hear the story they
just sounds more confusing than enraging
I'm like wait what what happened I think
I feel like what are you doing why why
are you ruining our family I don't
understand I think that would break me
like if we have a family together we
have like our kids are grown and then
you're like I'm just going out with one
ear one of our daughters friends yeah
hope you're okay with that
like know that we may go in geology and
we come rings like people hang out and
then I just marry one of them you know
marrying his friend uh Carrie she's my
girlfriend now she's my wife so hold off
more she's I think she wants to do
really what do you think what is that
marriage like what does that have to
imagine right now and you've talked to
20 year olds and no offense to any 20
year olds I'm not I just think that 40
is significantly different than 20
you're just in a different place I'm not
shitting on 20 year olds by any means
but what do you what do you think that's
like I mean it's got to be torture I
can't I don't know nothing in common
with it there's essentially children's
other things leading up to the person
doing that though it's not it's not
they're like I'm just so compelled by
you yeah I mean there's there's problems
and things and then you end up there
yeah I don't know that's crazy
you'd like it though what would I like
it marrying you'd probably marry a
Dalmatian after me after me with all
these thoughts words blah blah blah
talking yeah I mean II just want some
quiet after me yeah yeah like you get a
20 year old Dalmatian easy that's what's
next that's what you're saying yeah yeah
now not now after I son is grown and
again oh yeah yeah no you're right
you're right
yeah and then I'll get like five more
Brussels griffons and just like be alone
and Wilda know we'll live on the same
compound will do anything I wouldn't
mind yeah I'll be fine
we have this big it's eight acres you
know the thing is that Christina and
Carrie are friends I can tell it's such
the 20 year old new wife named Carrie
okay
so that the estate is appropriately
adjusted and you know Christine is taken
care of but Kari will also get to go to
school eventually you know college funds
beyond your wife when you guys when
she's ready to go to school she'll go
she's a yoga instructor that's all I do
they marry you know teach yoga here we
go
how do you know you're gay if you're
blind love the show I wonder which I see
the other thing about the blind and
wiping into the name wanted to ask the
follow-up that's been driving me crazy
if you're blind and can see people's and
see people are faces a biocide zones
that you can't any Jesus no one writes
the fucking word right how do you know
if you're an A or straight if you're a
blind
how'd you describe in your sexual
orientation I stop provoking how much I
needed the answer to this question let
me know what you think
just grab it but these are all things
people really wonder about or you know
this show is so important we're really
doing important work here nobody
actually Nations I really applaud him
for us I do too I never thought of it
silly as it is I applaud you that's
really silly but he's right so like
let's say you don't I mean it's a very
rigid gender privilege well I shouldn't
ask you a question isn't like you can't
ask like what do you prefer blonde to
brunette right I don't know you can't
even ask what your pronoun is because
you don't know what the difference who
you're looking at um yeah that's a great
day how do you know that's such a good
point
I guess when they have sexual encounters
yeah and they touch a vag and their legs
your doctor Ozel and your you know
people are sitting you know on Yap and
you're hugging people like yeah could
you get a boner with and you hug them
there you go yeah that's true do you
like those dirty pillows mashed against
you or not huh mmm very really good cool
we didn't get any closure on the wiping
question you just no sure don't you just
know man
you just know I like there you go no you
use your hand to wipe and then you smell
your hand like why would you smell the
paper wedding why did you go dear
because it's just you wouldn't
understand it is like some inside like
shit I don't know about
I talked to some funds and that's what
it is you're cute it's true Mikayla
here's a another email it's official
Tina is not the water after episode 400
been declared so Steven not only this
time the water champ but due to mommy
Tina's cowardice of declining the water
challenge oh god I think this time also
needs to be declared personality chance
as well you can tell that once the
challenge was suggested by Maria
Tina was legitimately upset proceeded to
insult Tom not to mention the
disrespectful comments about Tom's anus
in the opening minutes of the episode
our members all of which are very
negative personality traits I know I
certainly wouldn't want to hang out with
Christina after that said in Episode
four hundred all I do however believe in
second chances
nor for mommy team it to be a
personality water champion contender
so-called black kiss should be awarded a
Tom how Chi and the trip to Tahiti in
exchange for a black kiss should be
avoided unless the black kiss is
upgraded to a rusty trombone oh my god
PS how do you feel about user
submissions of a scripts in order to get
the King out of hiding
hmm I know you guys have tried to
contact him but haven't had much luck I
believe the only way to make him return
is to instigate a fart war god bless
Kyle can I tell you this I don't know
about farting and submitting that I have
to tell you something
King a stripper who as many of you know
is a a staple of the show oh I like him
so much and he rejects us all right
I love him he's an amazing guy great
violent so a lot of you know him as a
starter and a Berber I think - uh I
don't want to just paint him in that box
right you know a big thing that he also
has done that we've highlighted but
maybe not as much is he's also a glutton
right and he likes to overeat and gain
weight you're not gonna believe what he
looks like now really he has really put
on some weight stop it he's been doing
he hasn't been putting out as many fart
videos but he's been putting out the
stuffing himself it
well he's always evolving as an artist
we've never been able to just make him
do he's not a one-trick pony yeah but
you remember how he had like the little
who she idea a little belly again he was
like oh my doughnuts yes okay it's been
a while you got to see him no could
happen almost no no this goddamn
McDonald's is that a prosthetic belly
mattress these burrs make no surprise so
bad you think Papa W get some goddamn
chili dogs dude yeah by the way they
should accomplished yeah he's satisfied
now yeah you really did him in now it's
also hard fat it looked at hard it's
hard but I mean he's I would say he's
gained scent from the early days there's
got to be 60 80 pounds and this is real
late
yeah real weight man what's going on
with it I don't know look at that good
oh my god it looks pregnant
hey mother you can see the belly at the
bottom yeah those no I'll Oh oh my god
dude I don't like it I don't like it
there we go
yeah back to basics King won't get back
to the fart bids look I know the parts
of what we live for
yeah but I got to say I know how much
you wanted this so I just want to
congratulate him that's really cool man
also I wanted to point something out
yeah I feel like there's a new contest
evolving between the two of us yeah
firstly might I address that previous
gentleman's email about me not wanting
to compete in said water consumption
contest hey I don't need to compete
because I know I am the water Channel
you said that that day I mean it's very
silly
damn it I don't need to was known as a
cop-out it's not a cop-out you're
showboater your all when the lights are
on the cameras are rolling
you're oh I'm hydrating first of all
where's your water right now no really
where is it going on here Sonia why is
that because I'm too hydrated negative
you're drinking coffee and that's
negative water everyone knows that what
am i drinking oh look I have a Fiji
water right here and this is also loaded
with minerals and we learned from our
water sommelier eye but see the thing is
I had four of those before the
oh so now I'm that's asserting lie bro
why are you lying you never even even
had water today but you you lie you lie
to them all the time the mommies don't
even know how much you I not participate
my god a good point because you lie it's
like somebody saying I'm better at you
in basketball let's play and you go I
already know I'm better so I'm not going
to play I'm the goddess of water
consumption that sort of anybody to see
me perform live during my special even I
had to wherewithal to drink bottles of
water I mean I'm just that dedicated I
don't need secondly I feel like there's
a new game in town and I think I've
noticed over the years oh I've known you
for 12 years that's how long we've been
together
you know that generally speaking I'm
more observant than you and I notice
things and details and I read more I'm
generally more observant and I would say
that I'm the observation champ thank you
yes my go ahead fly - that would be and
this is like I would say this on the
witness stand there you are amongst the
least observant people that ever met
hello how so ahead
everything goes over your head like why
don't remember who was there memory yeah
that's a memory champ that's not doing
memories involve with observation now
I'm saying that in a room of things I
know it's different immediately like I
walk into my shrinks office every week
and I can Oh's out a new book and on the
Shelf by yes it is she did a very
observant I am sure okay well I noticed
everything is your mother couple
different hairstyle oh my gosh okay
I think you don't notice anything I
think the idea that you're actually
worked up about this and you can tell
how little I am because like it's like
you saying you're stronger than me okay
so I think it's cute that you'll get
yeah it's cute thank this and oh my gosh
I'm so observant when we on oh yeah when
we like clips
I'm the one that points out the
interesting my new shed no you don't
also know you don't at not only do you
never do
that's 100% mean you should have the
listeners laying on that you are not
only not observant I would
say you're you're oblivious to your den
that's a big word you're just you're not
aware whatever stuff you're let you're
not just present present this is not
about presence is observant this isn't
noticing things putting things together
I'm a connection I'm very good at that
you're just not very observant yeah I
think it would go you then Alice than me
they'll be the order Jesus
I noticed things about Ellis all the
time now the one thing I can't do and
you brought this up before sometimes I
can't read people emotionally that's a
big part of my observations right but
that's because of my upbringing I was
raised by a mentally ill person and I
don't always identify feelings properly
but I'm in therapy for it I'm with you
all the time and your and I'll say
something you're like and notice that
and I'm like yeah and then you go really
because I can't tell feelings and I've
told about because I'm fairly for that
that's part of being the observation
camp I think that I know don't think
that's a fraction of the observation
camps here's what I'm good at in
observation world I'm serious I can
listen to somebody talk and then I go oh
I know what they're you know that their
issues abroad had a pair of shoes on
that she did negative if we have dinner
with somebody and I'll be like did you
notice how he spoke to her his wife this
way and that happened that dynamic
oblique oh yeah no I'm like those you're
not observant that's not true all the
time I'll be like oh my gosh no you're
lying child to thing is because of this
and that I can break down why am i lying
why be able to say that you never say
did you notice that he talked and then I
go no I didn't know I always say yeah of
course I did and this dis Annette so
you're can't you're trying to say I
bring it up first because I'm the
observation champ okay I bring it up you
just agree with me let alone you're
stronger too I remember
so I'm definitely not stronger that I
will give you I don't have a full beard
and I am not strong you're not but my
vision and hearing is much better than
yours as well and my teeth are whiter
too though your sister I private eat in
purgatory I would give you yeah the
division is recent I used to have the
sharpest vision in California
I have this deteriorated how bad is it
now grandpa cataracts and caning it's
bad now really no it's not bad but I
mean I prefer to wear the glasses when
I'm reading when I'm looking at mostly
anything yeah your dad glasses yeah
everything is sharper sharper and
clearer your blue blockers you got those
on there's a review of this on iTunes
and the hey Hitler thing we can't seem
to shake as a meme Amish okay so many
people yelling nation and I had to talk
about it when I opened for you well
that's right we made a list of things
people were not allowed to do and number
one was don't shout hey Hitler it'll
interfere with recording this is hey
Hitler's this is a review on iTunes
which by the way of course I encourage
anyone who listens to the show
give us a 5-star well written nap jeans
tastic review only a five-star why go
anything less
hey Hitler's you got to get your life in
listening this podcast from high in
tight jeans dad boners lots of Stan Emma
and glass and they cover lots of ground
like burns Chrysler's fat ass the
podcasting world is the belt on the
media world and this podcast is the
buckle come on power RV that is by Nolan
from Winnipeg and a very observant
review I might add I knew this was
Canadian because it says Rogers is a
screen grab of the Rogers review that he
sent in Rogers Roger cellular I know
that that's because there can an
observant I've indicated you know I knew
that I knew that I do that yes I did
you're Canadian you didn't know I was
born and Windsor on terribly your
Canadian that's my fucking point yes and
I knew I knew Rogers I did it took me a
second gosh very soon we'll be joined by
the great wheeler Walker jr. the country
music singer you're a huge fan I really
like his stuff I've really enjoyed it
for a while now a lot of people think
you two are the same person
but I've gotten dozens of tweets maybe
hundreds about hey I've never seen you
two in the same room at the same time
blah blah blah so funny cuz I get the
same one with Claudia Schiffer
people are like oh my god and then
you're like not me tell me guys yeah
that was one of my early crushes shorter
than me it was just so pretty I was
gonna wait what made you think of her
fucking now I just think I'm Heidi Klum
but she has those little rabbit teeth
she's got those real feminine front -
rabbit teeth I thought I wanted my
veneers to look a little rad more
rabbity oh he did it he did it already
on these what my two college roommates
who you knew you know yeah we had a
poster of her somewhere in our house
wing in the kitchen
hiding I've had to color up yeah in
college
she's still rockin man she looks great
yes looks amazing so it kind of Germans
let's see here howdy Shifa oh yeah hi -
come my name is Krauts age so well I
don't know there she is I think just set
I tried to find a recent photo and she
looks good yeah how old is she probably
50 by now oh oh
hot mom hey hey hey hey we just we just
jump back in here we stopped now we're
rolling again as promised the great
country music the legend is growing
wheeler Walker jr. thank you for now
thank you for being here thank you guys
so much for having me all the podcasts
up till now has been fantastic I loved
every second it was a it was it's
actually there's a lot of reasons we
wanted to have you here one of them as
we were discussing a moment ago is I
keep getting tweet to say never seeing
you and wheeler Walker in the room at
the same time yeah I want to put that in
people I've seen a lot of people um
Photoshop your head onto my yeah album
cover yeah oh my goodness yeah I've seen
that too which is by the way if we were
the same guy you wouldn't need to so it
would just be you right to plant I've
heard that that like you're that I'm you
I've heard that Zach's you have heard
that Brent Hoffman do I've heard all
these different guys yeah everyone
thinks I'm some guy but I like to
everyone they think I am I like to get
you know be on their podcast here we are
talking while they are doing wouldn't
take too much special effects to to UM
have you talking to yourself right now
right and you know what they're going to
point out now is that we're on different
cameras the exam plan so we're not the
same
Tom I was talking those talk over each
other yeah yeah I mean it's like I mean
you gotta talk to talk talk well all
right here we go
fucking guys but then they're going to
say you just live it out if I wait
that's again the easiest thing to do you
have really similar beard color patterns
is what our length is pretty similar
today yeah by the way you're looking
good
thanks buddy I did Brett spud had a
blast
Brett but I love this whole Tom and go
and burnt Chrysler and yeah Brett the
bird thing is really cool because I love
how you guys are really like it's real
and you're real and it's also healthy
it's like yeah we lost a lot of weight
and I mean obviously I lost more but
yeah obviously you look if you look
fatter to you you just saw him recently
said Bert Bern's she said how fat does
he look Bert yeah I think well I didn't
really I didn't size him up too much
before but I was just walking and seeing
you I would say you're like a healthy
child yeah I mean I wouldn't if you'd
said you were big before I wouldn't know
like to me you just look like a kind of
a skinny right and how fat I mean but in
relation to Tom how much bigger is burnt
look then Tom I don't get myself in
trouble but I am here right now not say
I would say you look thinner that you
did yeah not even close to me I think I
think sighs I think he just got a better
cross shot
you're a fat count again Mike what are
you describe for what tell yeah yeah one
of the things I love this is you do
those so you know I love that like the
stern still like the old radio stuff
with robeson yeah yeah Bob's it's fun
it's fun but yeah he I think he's got
maybe a bigger friend like I feel like
he's always going to kind of look like a
bigger dude yeah you see toes diet that
he's on see the thing is he tries to
fight the tito's so he Kiara's tequila
right vodka sorry guy he drinks his
vodka but then he works out and he his
body perfectly reflects it he looks like
a guy that drinks a lot but then also
run yeah you can't you can't that's not
yeah I found this on the road which I
mean you guys get to fly in and you know
stay in hotels and chef and people don't
believe me but you really can't part
like a traveling musician you can't
party on the road it just doesn't work
how solid you're always moving lightly
legends are that you know they're just
fucking getting ripped every night and
yeah it's like you meet a oh you get you
could drop first of all we're always
leaving and going on to the next town so
yeah and all my friends of course for
you know you're getting laid in every
towns like I meet a girl we're going to
take her on the bus and then Tigger with
me to the next city right so what like
yeah I've done that but yeah it's nice
how what do you do is you don't you
don't uh you don't get late Yeah right
and I just found out I've just and I
hate to admit it it ruins my image but -
I'm playing with it I can't play with a
dog and talk at the same time cool
that's sorry I Betty come on dude my
problem is I can't have one beer
it doesn't I'd rather I'd much rather
have no alcohol than yeah one big I just
rather be sober than what one beard is
one beer I want a second yeah I don't
want to say like I'm alcoholic or
something but one beard to me and once
charge is pointless it's just yeah a
little taste of like the fun you could
have but the problem about being sober
is in you know like a music club is
you're the only fucking sober dude in
the whole place yeah and everyone's
looking at you so I'd rather just leave
yeah I don't do anything you mean I
having a beer isn't problem I don't I
like the one that I keep going down with
his booze like if I have a vodka drink
or something now then I want two or
three you know like that's what's up so
I don't even start
and I just go I don't like hanging out
late in these loud bang I'm like an old
guy yeah I don't yeah and I'm the same
way which is you know because the pussy
King - yeah how is that because you're a
persona I mean from what I'm not a no
offense I'm not a huge country fan per
se but we love your videos I love them
because they're so provocative and
you're out there and you kind of do come
across as the pussy king he is the pussy
right you're tired yeah that's my thing
was I wanted to kind of Mark myself on
this new record was like I said before
I'm you know Elvis was the king and
Michael Jackson was the King of Pop like
what am i you know there's only one left
right yeah the pussy kings yeah I'll
just once you once you
start saying it you know like Stern king
of all media you start saying I just
start saying to put the king yeah and
that sticks oh by the way yeah yeah
let's see what you got here's the new
record Wow Wow oh this looks great
and a most digital download inside look
at the band sticker band from Walmart
Target and Best Buy which is kind of
mine out because you know our goal was
to have the number-one country album in
the country but these country fans still
fucking buy CDs from like Walmart sure
so weird
we won here's something fucked up yeah
my uh it's kind of hard to say no after
I phrase it like that but um we had the
fifth best-selling country album in
America last week that's crazy
and congratulations thanks man but on
the Billboard country charts were number
10 why is that because they do this new
fuckin thing to keep the Keith Urban's
of the world happy that they now
incorporate like streaming and radio
plays in it they keep that they they
lend that in they like have a weird like
algorithm and so like you know because
to them and I guess it's true which is a
Keith Urban is more popular than me
right I don't see that but okay well
sing but well I don't like what's a role
to the run to this yeah I like to track
their flow inside a you sir good side a
of this wheeler Walker junior album all
wheeler side a has pussy king fucking
around
featuring Casey Walker ex-wife oh the
next track is Puss in Boots
next is finger up my butt and next is
summers in Kentucky this is great and
then side B we have drunk sluts amazing
ain't got enough dick to go around if my
dick is up why am i down yeah small town
Saturday night pictures on my phone and
then poon to round out the album times
of the main rating test yeah this is
great
oh yeah I remember this you guys do you
need koozies right yeah oh yeah dude I
think who needs or cozies cookies know
what they're called you mustn't yeah the
first album I remember tastic I remember
redneck shit that was a good video then
there's a yeah I remember this can't
fuck you off on mine
fuck you bitch eatin pussy kickin ass
fighting fucking in fart and sit on my
face which one of you queer is going to
suck my dick you're amazed what better
off beaten off he does now by the way I
gotta get a lot of shit recently about
how homophobic which I'm starting to get
pissed about I'm like hmm because the
interviewers you know will do a lot of
phone interviews you know you know which
one equi is going to suck my dick you
know that right
it's like is that homophobic like no
it's homosexual yeah you're asking them
to suck your dick it's like I'm the only
fucking guy in country music talking
about guys blowing me yes get treated so
drunk that do what I'm trying to do is
obviously piss off Nashville and yeah I
just really get off on pissing people
off I want to ask you this because I
didn't grow up really in the country but
I did for a while live in Florida and it
started to get you know just part of the
culture started get into it more and so
actually I've been - I went to a Clint
Black concert I started to hear Hank
Williams jr. stuff like that was very
Sam yeah doesn't mean that so I started
to hear some of the music there's a lot
of like nice bullshit like I went and
especially in that cult in the country
culture you're one of the guys who's
actually being like a little more like
like it's not all fucking hugs and
kisses man like you're kind of talking
some shit yeah you talked I was trying
to point and what used to piss me off is
I because I know a lot of these guys and
then they'll press cut on the album and
I'll be like man I got some fucking
pussy last night but I'm like why are
you saving the interesting shit for
often like more that yeah I mean I know
what you got to pay for your Butler and
private planes yeah yeah I know they
can't play that shit on the radio but
it's like wouldn't it be nice if someone
because the biggest genre in the world
right in America I'm sure by far is
hip-hop because it was going and that
stuff's hard X I don't know all like an
adult controvert and it's also like
beefs and like willing to fight now you
talk shit about some of the other guys
even though yeah one guy I'm that I talk
shit about on the on this song poon
actually texted me the other day saying
that he was honored really so I thought
that was cool you say who it is or no
yeah I'll say it it's got Jay Cohen who
was a oh in a big country we went to
high school in the same city no way
yeah beats yeah so I'm I always like it
when you know
and he said he was honored to yet I mean
to fans they'll probably be pissed to
know that like the guy even has my
number but I met him he's a nice guy
yeah a nice guy and like in my head you
know we all I did
poon is just a song where I just kind of
rip on all the and I literally I took
the iTunes country charts from that day
that was in the studio and it made them
all rhyme you know you know really
fucking talented at this man
yeah I didn't I ask you this though
because I know like like we were just
talking about how country stars you're
expected to be super nice all the time
and really accommodating to the fans
like Garth Brooks we follow him on
social media
anything yeah yeah I agree I don't think
he's fantastic that gets me in trouble a
lot too which is I fucking hate Garth
Brooks I hate him tails and I think his
music is this shit I could go on for an
hour but I think he's part he's part of
the reason country music got shitty yeah
he was the first guy who kind of went
pop yeah and kind of took the country
all this like any pander so much it's so
fake I find him to be very listen Jenny
way those G alerts Euler Euler what's
that he'll have on Twitter it's like
it's like a flashing letter G G alert
and then he'll you'll see you'll see him
in his fucking nose mansion like it's a
G alert he's like I don't know if I can
tell you guys it's like some top secret
that you know you're like waiting for
like yeah you know what this big news
like him he's retiring whatever it is
him and the G alert is that he's playing
Atlanta yeah that's what I was just
saying like I follow him on Instagram
and he'll be like big news big surprise
swap up to see you I blow up to see it
and then you're like and he's like I'm
coming to Bossier City and you're like
that's a surprise asshole so we're going
to go there anyways it's not breaking
news he's always in studio G yeah and
like a CD is where they do the trio yeah
he'll also refer to himself and G it's
like when they're singing happy birthday
he's like happy birthday to G that's it
to himself and calls himself to you like
do you fucking and that's why I get
pissed because I think the truth because
so he's I don't know this much about his
I don't know the man but he was married
he just do a trash no he's married
before but they're very before then does
it do it with Trisha Yearwood now he's
married to Trisha Yearwood there's
obviously a lot of shitty ain't singing
about right and
passing it I have that's the song we
want to hear right yeah you know so
that's like it's like energy music used
to be about the truth and now it's just
a bunch of bulls you know hold it again
like because only you had like when you
sell tickets at any level you know you
have you subjects because people want to
see you you have fans and I get it that
like you know you're going to be
obviously you're appreciative you want
to be nice to your fans you want to say
but the level I like it just seems
disingenuous today ha
yeah I'm so I'm so overwhelmed and
getting shout out to every single person
that follows him on Twitter like eat bro
yeah how can you be sorry I made some I
do on podcast a lot interrupting people
and I stopped doing no it's all good
we're good we cut out that part I
interrupted Christina was really
embarrassing but well I could say wish I
had a we're now on Facebook I really
wasn't sure about the velar art yeah a
friend of mine said something they just
made all kinds of sense she should think
of it more as a conversation I throw up
in my mouth like that
but I'm already finding out on my own so
it's wiping the walls out between you
and me I really like looks like a that's
like a video yeah like you trying me to
do it on the Internet yeah it is like a
gay video well I am it allows us into
each others worlds alright I guess in my
case hotel room I think about things I
want to post I want to post cool stuff
slick stuff most of them are post is
gonna be raw stuff like this well that's
not wrong no not at all he's wearing all
this bring his own merch so this is
really a conversation and I say let the
conversation begin no contrived and
there's no there's no naturalness to
that I like your your uncle trying out
social media yeah that's exactly how it
ended now
Dolly Parton is famous for being super
fan friendly like I know that she lets
people like sleep on her front lawn or
I've heard around so she's got a
Dollywood out yeah outside of Nashville
now do you let people do that to you do
you let people sleep out on your lawn
like how no no no yeah I think is I have
a on them this is why I think I might
make you unpopular and ountry I think
what people dig about me is like if you
look at my comment it
all kind of like the Tom and Bert thing
was just like it was a lot of people
just your fucking fat you fuck you so
yeah all my comments are just fans like
like not the tour and they're like
you're not to play my city fuck you it's
a bunch of a bunch of all my fans tell
me to go fuck myself
which I kind of appreciate which is so
that I'll go I'll go on to Twitter and
just be like this if you tweet me your
city one more time I ain't come into it
ever Wow and so because I'm just sick of
them just being like yeah they don't
know how tours work it's not like yeah
Axl doesn't go through his Twitter and
see where the fans want to play an
intake date yeah I mean I keep
explaining too that I therefore Eddie's
for us like you know a promoter
approaches me with a routing and yet
except that we don't and in
predetermined yeah well me more than you
I would bet because I got the band
yes true and we're out he's like Toronto
is not on the way between Nashville and
Chattanooga we can go up to fucking
Panda like we'll add it bitch yet
exactly alright listen guy who I'm on my
facebook and tell me if you guys have
found either facebook is by far the
meanest i don't know why i don't yeah i
think also those whatever is common it's
it's there right like twitter kind of
goes well I think maybe Facebook or
people who haven't moved on to the other
things and they're still maybe there's
other stuff but there's a guy who's just
says who's from England just has come to
the UK you fucking loser and he's the
first post he's the first guy to comment
on everything everything every time you
post it was just a UK you fucking losers
like plaint ticket to England for
fucking six dudes to get out like yeah
do do I have an audience there I don't
know I mean no one have you gotten the
how much would it cost to book you so
you're supposed to be like 100 bucks
like people sometimes how much does it
cost I'll get a lot of those I'm just
like you know just like you know how
much does it cost for me for you to play
my bachelor party like talk to my
fucking people I don't know you know I
don't negotiate that and they're always
you know like jokingly but it doesn't
come off as like you can fuck my sister
while you're there I'm like all right
cool well then I'll take two grand off
the yeah Troy now this is probably an
obvious question but did you fuck her on
the back of it yeah I was going to ask
when do you hook up no those were all I
wanted to I mean those were all
Nashville models hmm who I'm who fucking
who were cool but I'm the insight well
he would see better in seed yeah there's
a poster that comes with a poster oh
cool
open it up there's a desert King poster
so we had these girls spell w w jr. with
their legs Wow
and a couple of the girls complain that
we showed their face they did complain
yeah I think they only want to show
their crotch and they're humming sure
now do you get any pushback from the
religious communities because country
music I mean we're talking that's a
bobble bill yeah water I don't know that
I think I'm doing is anti Bert you know
it's pussy anti-religion dick I guess to
son oh wow that's what you're saying
it's risque I mean yeah I know I do get
I mean if you were to go to my iTunes
page it's like oh wow its five-star it's
wow it's a hundred and oh you got the
big here's the big one if you guys want
to take a look at yeah yeah I see ww jr.
yeah yeah that's great looks good and
these girls are like you can see my face
yeah yeah I can see how that's offensive
to women but to me it was her it wasn't
this is where I get in trouble because
to me I understand how that I understand
how that's misogynistic just because I'm
serving them as letters but to me it
sure I thought it'd be cool to have them
spell out my name I wasn't thinking like
that yeah you know what's interesting
too is that in this day and age and
feminism a lot of women are saying that
this is empowerment right like a hot
chick and don't call me slut like I can
put my that girl actually Instagram
she's like her picture she's like I work
she said I worked hard for this but it's
really cool to it and she was excited
I'm saying a lot of women see they flip
it I don't know if I agree with it in
this other way yeah maybe I just don't I
don't take anymore but I love vagina can
read lyrics yeah that's so cool yeah I'm
inside there's not a bummer that you
know I spent that much time on the hard
work that no one's going to see that's
what I like to bring it no it's awesome
man you know what I like to the
attention to the the pussy details if
you look there's a lot of camel toe and
then you can actually see like some
badge oh yeah we let me get her lips
right here you can see oh I didn't even
fuckin but what about right here
look at the last week lips see the
regime hold on let me see look it's
really cool yeah look at the last two
you can funny
she just got drill one gurning one one
of the girls on her boob was popping out
we had to fix it info
chef I thought roof you didn't you
didn't get help I don't know these these
girls I don't know how they found five
girls in Nashville who didn't know the
fuck I was but I've never seen five
girls that less interested in me than
those really yeah no I mean I cannot be
now I don't know it's like what's it
like being a country like what's it like
being a musician and I know you're going
to be honest about it or you're going to
shows people are there to see you you're
singing songs they're excited about
thing and meeting the girls I mean they
must go nuts yes yeah well it's kind of
what I sing about on the new record with
the new ones called ol wheeler just
because I because I'm talkin old man and
like why you laugh was about that I know
I was obviously the plug know it's such
a you know oh oh yes I don't I'm not in
the country world is yelling there's no
you are connect you're from LA I grew up
I'm just I just for me it's funny
because Stanley I just been around the
South so much and spent so much time I
mean I lived in Florida and Carolina
it's just like oh hey there's old it's
just money yeah well there's I'm a huge
Waylon Jennings fan there was and
there's a Waylon album called old Waylon
so I'm just like playing all the the old
you know like really the album was just
about my last year on the was like and I
was talking about before I've just I
feel like I'm just you know getting gray
in my beard and like you're meeting
these girls who are snapchat and so you
know instagramming you naked pics on the
DM and like I just don't know that like
trying to figure out that like I feel
like I'm a at a time almost you know
like I've considered myself although you
wouldn't be tell it by the pussy King
poster like an old style Southern
gentleman mmm-hmm as much as the guy who
sings pussy King can say that and then
it's like you meet a girl and she'll
just fucking text you or twat you know
it's like it's crazy in here it's like
so weird for me like because I'm at the
age of when seeing a naked girl in a
Playboy was the biggest fucking deal you
could think of them the same and now
girls will send you like basically you
know I don't like OBGYN fucking but then
they expect you to send your dick pic -
I don't
I won't do it why not even because I
don't want it to just dude that it's
never happened to me no-one's ever
texted me a pussy pictures or anything
but I always think that like if I were
on the market Rowe days one thing I
would never do is text my dick town out
yeah because my mom my buddies are like
well you don't put your face in it and
it's fine it's like that doesn't mean
anything it doesn't if a picture also
I'm a grower not a show or as they yeah
sure I know Ari was in here before last
week and he said he had enormous balls I
also feel like I'm a grower with my
balls two demands grow yeah I mean they
don't actually grow but they're you know
you can find me on the wrong day and
it'll look like a fucking baby yeah I'm
that too and then I might but like his
mother's okay
but you've got really nice oh yeah your
ears are exemplary yeah yeah yeah but
but dick wise its writ like last week I
did a trim you know on the hair and it
was just like it'd been a few days and
you're like whoa your hog looks
different today
yeah yeah yeah I know the operative
thing is it look different that day so
like every day well I mean like my new
thing is trying to get ready for this
tour we got coming up I've been like
exercising and running like when I run
my dicks like this people can see on the
podcast I'm holding two fingers very
quick when I run my dick sucking
shrivels up yeah so but then someone
wants a dick pic I don't want to sit
there for 10 hours getting ready and
jacking off yeah to look awesome yeah
yeah I do I want to see I also want to
see the tits in the territory
wait do you have is there anyone that
you're dating or young buddy I'm seeing
somebody right now in in a in Nashville
who um do you know this podcast and I've
been a problem of mine and I'm super
hyper focused on right now because a
guide the other day text tweeted me that
I can't finish a complete I was on Rogan
I didn't finish one complete sentence
and now it's in my head so I'm now I got
it I'm talking all over the place but uh
I was on this podcast called uh guys we
fucked unit five oh yeah I've heard of
it so it's talker this very pop yeah I
did some promo in New York and they had
they'd emailed my people last year they
want to use some my songs in their
podcast I'm like yeah sounds good like a
next time you're in New York just come
do the podcast and I'm
it's just it's a really cool podcast
early to girls just talk like kind of
nasty yeah you know sex talk about their
real experiences right yeah which is
almost like you know what guys do all
the time but they do it and it's really
cool I think empowering to me that to me
that's empowering talking about you know
they call it the anti slut-shaming like
yeah odka and I went on it and I told a
bunch of details and my lady friend was
none too happy about that sure and so so
to keep her from it I said I'd refer to
as a girl I used to see Oh blank so
which I thought was helping the
situation right because I was like an
old story yes so people saw me out in
Nashville with this girl they wouldn't
be like oh I heard you talking about
suck stories with her yeah I thought I
was protecting her and it actually was a
double whammy were number one I was
talking explicit shit about her yeah and
also too I was saying on a podcast that
I wasn't singer anymore out here right
so it's fine so I got it I'm trying to
watch what I say now on on pot again
yeah that's all good man yeah I mean I
think you didn't you were you had the
good intention well also to you get
those putt you forget how big these
fucking podcast like yeah the reason I
said and not to be rude to her but I was
just like there's no way she's ever I
mean there's 8 million podcasts why
would you listen to this one that make
sense then she did she's smart and she
likes hear unless you were you were on a
podcast with like I don't know what
those girls look like but they're
probably like two hot chicks right yeah
I'm not banging dudes so of course your
lady's gonna be like oh you're saying
you would listen if I was oh yeah I
really first of all you're not doing my
show and then secondly would talk about
those like yeah I'm sure they're lovely
no are they comics I think so yeah
but yeah you should I don't want to play
I've got to plug my album in their
pocket yeah oh yeah we play so I'm
jumping songs out of this new album
allow yeah if you want to here's one
thing which is why I'm Who I am is my
independence which is whether you want
to play it or not just to let you know I
own my Master's I own my song you know
like it was an important thing for me to
own everything so like yeah some kind of
shitty come you know burger company
wants to use my you know Carl's jr.
wants to play fuck you bitch well
carousel Anita burger I can say like I
literally own it like I can know it and
I've had this before two friends want to
use it for a thing here there and I just
say you know if I know they don't have
money if it's like a podcast let's just
say so it won't get flagged if we play
it on something it might get what's
happened and they happened with Rogen
before which is it gets flagged because
of the distribution company but the
flagging it doesn't matter there's like
comes back around to me and I say don't
let it go yeah great yeah I mean you
have a new album out it's doing really
well and the tour is going to kick off
soon yeah what's when will this come out
this comes out in a day or two okay so
yeah probably a couple weeks from now
and I meant to text my manager to see
what markets it's weird is there a site
to buy tickets oh yeah my website which
is wheeler Walker jr. calm there you go
then probably backslash tour I think for
the two days no I had a fun well they
don't really because they I'd tweet me
where you plan on this tour always know
that shits ridiculous yeah I also get
this you know will plug that I'm in
whatever going to Philly then the tweet
comes in are you in Philly now I go yeah
shows tonight yes where and like dude oh
dude I'll think that I'm like who what
times open or go on yeah and you know
it's like you know yeah what time you go
on like I don't want not only do I not
like how fuckin lazy are you have like
also I want you to see the open Google
yeah yeah I know it's like just fuckin
come on look it up now wait is there a
real problem with you in Georgia Florida
line Florina well on Georgia line I
don't know that I went I went after
country group here's the big their
massive religion massive for some what I
like having Christina here because she's
similar doesn't know this world so I can
just explain it really simply country
music used to be really fucking good and
then it became white people pop music
like to stuff the company it's like if
after this like if Tom played you floor
a Georgia line you would told you that
was a kid country song your mind would
be fucking blown because it was like it
doesn't it's just it's New Kids on the
Block right that's like the note that be
like a number one country song yeah it's
just it's just pop crap which is it's
kind of someone described the other day
house because people are trying to
big argument which I don't really give
that much of a shit about but you know
what is country music these days and one
of my friends her definition which a
friend told her was just country music
is now defined it's just whatever white
people are listening to hmm it's not a
bad description which is they're
actually taking because you know the old
cliche about like whatever school in New
York or LA is like gets to the south you
know ten years later right it's true in
music too which is like a lot of these
beats and all those sound like it's kind
of like hip-hop from like 10 or 15 years
ago yeah it's like it sounds like fuckin
MC Hammer or Milli Vanilli yeah yeah and
it's stuck in garbage and so my thing
was I'm going to play real country music
and since I'm playing real country no
one's going to fucking play it anyway
because I want real country right well I
may as well not censor my because
everyone would want to sing dirty if
they could well who do you hate the most
in country music right now who's the
worst it's not really hate but um the
worst artists are definitely Florida
Georgia line is this guy's Sam hunt
mm-hmm who on and what I'm trying to
give my words to go because all these
people by the way now that I'm on the
charts they they don't come after me but
they're people B's you know can you
knock it off a little really they'll
reach out about that I've had a couple
people reach up none none of these are
these guys but I've met these people the
problem is not a problem but you me
they're not bad people you know you mean
they're like happy like you try a
friends who are comics who are like
super nice guys who aren't fucking funny
right right right but what do you do but
yeah so are like are we just here last
yeah yeah no but yeah I'm doing his
thing because I'm in town for the next
week I'm doing a the punch-drunk thing
tomorrow what's that that's a trade war
podcaster yeah that was fun good good
good was that we fund yeah yeah I'm
doing to kill Tony tonight that is fun
is that really fine
yeah I've really found and that's why I
love doing this stuff is because radios
pretty much banned me yeah and it's
almost like a big fuck you to just suck
you suck this mainstream I'll tell you
with with a lot of the podcasts like we
talking about you're reaching more
people to that's the thing too is I and
and we talked about it before I actually
talked about it on Rogen witches and
I've got the numbers to prove it Rogan
is bigger than SNL if you're musician
for sure like people to understand like
I'm going through the back door you know
like yeah when we
put it out I was like fuck you know I
can't get on the radio and they won't
even have me on the radio to interview
me without it or even play or bleep it
out you just built up just banned even
nobody even listens to terrestrial radio
anymore
some do I mean some so mom market some
genres still have ountry is a country
has a bell right there's a lot of people
who like France who don't have cassette
players in their class true hey and
listen to radio and buy go to Walmart to
buy sweetie you have any relationship
with Toby Keith no but I heard a rumor
that he wanted me to open a show but I
didn't I don't know if I ever panned out
really W I mean I know it didn't pan out
is that I don't know if it you imagine
like I'm sure his draw is unreal yeah
for you to go out there and do the pussy
King I'd love to look at yeah I think
that's other problem too is we couldn't
really we couldn't really tour until I
could headline because no one would have
me know I can't help anybody because a
lot of these country you know like
Tobias Toby Keith would be parents and
the two little girls I'm I can't sing
that doesn't Toby Keith have a rib place
he has a restaurant like Toby Keith I
love these ribs or something yeah I'm
serious if I remember doing like
military's overseas red white and blue I
love these ribs in my view and here he
and now I'm called shocking y'all yeah
more to Jordan I just opened up a
restaurant Nashville which is I can only
me if their foods if their foods twice
as good as their music is still shit now
will you be opening a pussy king
restaurant we're doing it we're doing a
pussy pussy king I actually just reached
out to the two of these guys who make
pocket pussies to see if they want to
make special wheelie so can I pull up
the van right like a like that you play
phone this is the that video is really
good so you're going to do a pocket
pussy G but nothing for restaurants or
food no I ain't got that kind of cash
yet I mean once I can yeah I mean it's
we're doing a whole we're doing the the
vivo one is that the one to play yeah
which which song will 2020 mint pussy
king yeah if that's it like is home I'll
show you
is it better to play this one oh you're
VEVO channel yeah that's the real one
that's the real okay you're really kind
of an outlaw country music in this video
we're
so the leather
[Music]
there's no the vocal really might be oh
yeah and walking back through the
addition and Austin's would think that
my dick is better than amber you will
then open one watch it won't pound away
Frank the inspector still keep legs or
performance okay
you got agent girl who puts it inside
this person thinks anal doesn't count
it just it includes my big feel my hands
[Music]
you could get into this Turner no I
guess I like it us on it yeah real
I don't like bullshit I don't like dark
when I was on the when I was on the road
yeah girls ask me all the time I'm like
maybe I am the pussy kill you know yeah
how'd you do you get a lot of push back
off from the women scripts in South and
Elena sausage from mouth to well though
the smart women kind of get it the fun
of it please but yes I do
my gonna be a lot meaner next year for
his daughter gonna I bet your show is
funder I'd like to do good life yeah
markdown did this triple a quality with
awful miniature skirts in Nashville
break in the marketplace to what my
dears I did this video if you can't name
is Cameron Crowe but not that one
are you being serious yeah today yeah
it's a great video a great really great
graphic yeah click rhogam oh yes I love
that
[Music]
Wow the best way I would describe it it
just feels like a throwback to real
country music well that's not what this
one is this song especially which is you
know it's here and all that like I said
kind of shitty white boy rap on the
radio yeah let's do the old-time like
Jerry Reed kind of country function so
you grew up did you grow up in natural I
grew up in Kentucky and my mom and all
my family from Nashville so it's really
strange right now I don't know if you
guys know but Nashville's like the
hippest city in the world
no it's always been there I like it my
last you know as I knew it as a kid when
it was like a fucking ghost town yeah
and now it's the rent fucking critically
since I've been a kid it becomes like
super hits place and I could barely
afford it I got a buddy there I can't
believe I'm so blown away that you're
not getting late every night I'm gonna
show you a lot I do okay I do okay but I
think the secret is I was talking to a
buddy of mine the other day just about
this is secret is to party of between
tours yeah yeah so going around Nash I
mean it's easier I can meet girls in
Nashville going out to bars and stuff
right why me one and fucking Boise when
it's just some random girl who's like um
you got to get through that tour which
is also work you got to have stand in LA
to get through that stay yeah I need
more stand Ahmad because the last tour I
am I went a little too crazy and not a
joke I put myself in the hospital for
real yeah at the tour engine and I was
and what happened was I am the tour I
ended in LA and it's kind of a secret
but I don't really give a shit anymore
which is we're doing a TV special mm-hmm
and I'm touring it in LA I had some
meetings about this wheel while Katrine
your TV special we were in this big
fancy Hollywood building
wherever was Beverly Hills and the tour
ended the night before and I barked on
myself in the fuckin meeting with all
these suits there and almost lost the
show because I think they thought I was
on heroin or drugs or some shit I was
just exhausted from I went too hard on
the tour I'm with you dude I know
exactly what you're talking about okay
cool yeah I was because it was it was
really exhausting so what happened was I
called I called my family just like you
know I'm sick so she leave me alone for
a couple days and I went back to the
hotel and 48 hours later or no I see was
24 hours later I heard banging on my
door and they were about to break down
the door
they had the tour manager come over and
they hadn't heard from me for what
happened was I passed out I was so
exhausted from the tour and I was so
sick didn't wake up for 24 hours they
were about to London down the Haute you
know I had to I had those thing locked
they're about to bust on the hotel room
door and then they had to take me to the
hospital and like put the IVs and oh my
yeah I've been I haven't had it like
that but I would say even without
partying's I'm not a big party guy I've
had a tour where you know it was a
different city every night four or five
nights a week three weeks in a row one
we got then back to three weeks in a row
and at the end of like the third month
of that I just fully broke down got like
really sick you know again yeah I think
two of my friends I'm talking about I
think there was although I don't want a
minute probably mental sure has you know
part of it too which was just like
emotionally and physically drained and
you know like they filled me up with
with fluids at the at the emergency room
and I guess it helped but I still I mean
it took two weeks for me to really kind
of be yet touring actually most people
and I was one of these people never you
heard about like big stars yeah sound
like thought you're like to have like
yeah you're like but it sounds like
bullshit like like they suffering from
exhaustion and then if you actually tour
it's the one thing that when you you see
it on the news with somebody you start
to have empathy for you're like oh yeah
a person I believe that like they're
actually really sit and you hear about
those fuckers like let's say Garth
Brooks for example who I heard and I
can't say this for a fact but I'm pretty
sure I'm right someone told me he has a
Vegas
see and he went out but he wants to
sleep at home so he walks out of the gig
and gets on a private plane and they
flying back to wherever he's he doesn't
sleep yeah yes there's a nurse artist at
that level now you know which fair to
say I'm pretty fucking far from that
yeah who do tours were they they just
least sleep in their own place every
night it will now be great they walk out
the back of the arena if you're that
rich yeah I know so I fell did had that
thing where so he got an offer he was in
an interview saying that he got an offer
to do a private gig in the Bahamas but
for like a super wealthy people but for
like ten people and so the the you know
what he required was you know obviously
extraordinary amount of money he would
not mingle pre-show that's imperative
flew in the in he's like it has to be
set up like this they introduced him he
came and he did the show walked out and
flew back from the Bahamas no Baba for
10 people yeah but it was for you know
probably seven figures I mean that's the
only sometimes those are the like I'll
get it like a you know a bachelor party
or some weird private party that will
pay for the rest of the tour yeah
so it's touring is so fucking with the
bandits I bet you at a bachelor party
probably a really fun yeah you'd be a
great act but we actually not not to act
too diva but we do have to my people
tell him like you know he ain't going to
the titty bar with you after what I
don't want to do what hang out with you
all night yeah you're not buying my
friendship right that's two extenders XM
we live inside Studio G where's the
jihad navigation some douche bag welcome
to inside Studio G where music is first
here and acting like you got a million
really cool right because I what I was
gonna say before was so I had a when I
had the first record I was kind of
shopping around I did meet at a Capitol
Records it didn't take to do nothing
against them but it would have been the
completely wrong place to do it because
they don't know how to market it they
you know their thing is go to radio go
to MTV all the shit I couldn't do but it
was nice then to meet with me nice dudes
but I was in the lobby the lobby they
had all every capital album that had
gone
and you know what diamond is diamond you
know platinum is a million copies right
and diamond they have this new thing
called diamond which is ten million ten
million they had up they had they had a
plaque of every diamond album the
capital ever put out which was it
literally was it was like Dark Side of
the Moon and then every Beatles album
and pretty much every Garth Brooks
albums Wow then you think about the
Beatles which is like you know back in
the old days and there's four of them
into art Brooke is just fucking him and
he had like fuckin ten of these this
crazy man I mean this guy's got more he
played a Rupp Arena which is a big arena
where my hometown
that's 23,000 he played two sold-out
shows there in one night Jesus okay
earlier this year I did a gig in
Edmonton at a theater I was there the
same week as him and he was doing
wherever the Oilers play which is like
take about twenty thousand he did nine
oh man
nine rolls out I think it's Rogers Arena
or something pretty crazy that's the
thing is that if you're that popular
you've got to be so detached from what
the thing in reality anyone I think he's
proving here that he's detached yeah but
he's trying
that's things trying me a pair of you
them but he's also don't forget he's
he's actually not he still sells tickets
like a motherfucker yes he's also not
adapting well this new world you had
shits not on iTunes it's not on Spotify
why here he thinks it's a ripoff and he
people ripoff to them to him know him oh
oh I I mean I don't know what the
specific things are he's like he wanted
iTunes is what I heard was he wanted
iTunes to not still had the ability he's
like their albums the pieces were you
can't I want you to be able to sell
single tracks
oh he's and uh I didn't like well
couldn't he do like album only salesman
they they're like the son what we do
here yeah and here's his I think he was
just like well I'm Garth Brooks you I
make the rules and yet we're Apple no no
you don't how does he tell his albums
and he actually tried to uh this is how
dummy is he he um he built a website
where he actually that I'm making the
work the term up but like instead of
mp3s they were like Garth P threes but
but I'm not I'm making that up but if
you P threes and yeah it was
EP yet he invented his own format what
and had his fans by it's just directly
from him Wow
but he just signed you can buy to me to
digitally and I'll give him a nice plug
he just signed an exclusive 'if the
first cut he's now you can buy his album
digitally at Amazon oh they let him do
it now if he's a lot of these videos
here these stupid shit there's a PC
Amazon Lobos behind uh is because he's
only he finally like we're talking about
a guy who got into the digital music
world like three months ago yeah
literally like the bit in social mania
yeah I got and his new albums don't sell
happen huh is so angry me happy birdie
see that by the way okay look at the
rage on his face well would that he know
that knock happens look at the rage and
he's like that's supposed to happen look
at someone I got it whoever's not on the
fucking door what I'm doing and if I
watched it thinking he loves money
updates is it supposed to happen do you
think and thank God nothing unexpected
happen in for that G alert alert
so there ya are because like might the
arena in my hometown's 23,000 s correct
I'll bet I'll bet he was just like I'll
bet his runs this shit is just like
23,000 like that's not even worked our
time he's like will do too because that
might some friends of mine when they
said like the you know the stairway it's
like got Pat it was like congested
because people leave in and coming in he
does a long show - he's like the shows
were 23,000 people two sold-out shows
one 631 930 wow he did that video only
we have the drop where he's talking
about exact you know people email me
that like during the show they've been
looking at the guy doing the lighting
and they're like oh yeah it's like yeah
man I mean that's people can they get
into everybody not just there for me
they're looking at the lighting guy and
Olivia he's trying to give credit to the
lighting guy the grip guy they get these
these are the ones that are doing the
work I'm not doing the work
I'm just different me happy bird gee so
give him give them the money yeah but I
chopped it up right he's like yes he's
the one really doing the worker the
lighting man gets 30% know about this
man right here you say another so what
is your regimen now what exactly like
the maintance I'm not really not I mean
I don't dislike him he actually had a
but I think that would be like can I
just get a hit this year to test your
bro Ritter advice in front of - great
song - lettuce you ain't Lord that's oh
right Marion blade that was that was
weird
a friend of mine who I'm playing a gig
with next week in Nashville a charity
gig he just opened up for him and I saw
a video that on in Surrey I mean it's
crazy it's like don't you feel like
country music nowadays is almost
underground music like the big stars
aren't like the real world big stars
like yeah but they fill a fucking pack
arenas wherever they Arena but like
these guys wouldn't hold a candle same
wise to like a Kim Kardashian or a Kanye
or any right you know it's like they're
not in our Lady Gaga but they probably
do as much business oh they like I'll
bet Garth Brooks is 20 20 50 times
bigger than Lady gaga
Lady Gaga's on the news all that you
know right yeah we white hair you are
look like if Garth Brooks is at all
those diamond records I mean
Gaga Katy Perry they've never had a know
even half that by the way nobody would
ever allow what Katie Couric if it had
been the reverse so there's been like a
guy interview reason to touch I just I'm
just behind you this is your taper we're
your tits look great you mind if I just
do it all right
wow they are they're real Ness is a
weird those but you're right it is
something that Garth didn't adapt to
this digital era
I mean Lady Gaga knew his mom's called
man versus machine versus right their
adversarial attitude towards social mean
yeah the Machine won the machine because
lady Lady Gaga swap it's on Twitter and
she's got gazillion you know Millennials
and girth didn't get that audience I
guess huh
but not to be not to be on iTunes you're
not in the grazie
must be on Spotify yeah Kida nowadays
just making Spotify playlist try and but
yet to me he was kind of a turning point
when everything turned member the Easter
gets fat asked up to those fucking wires
he would fly to the arena but that's not
like what really Nelson never did that
shit you know he runs a Bon Jovi yeah so
to me he was the first one to kind of
turn country into self you just suck Fi
so do you think the girth Brooks is
responsible for the sukkah fication of
country he was the beginning of it I
mean yeah in a weird way I mean now
compared to the shit of out there now he
sounds like fuckin Woody Guthrie you
know he sounds like you know he sounds
old-school compared to what's out there
now but at the time I just remember
being in high school in Kentucky and
like you'd walk into a room and the
teachers and the kids together we're
singing friends in low places like it
was like Glee or something like with the
biggest fucking song in the world and I
remember just hating those fucking songs
yeah and they assign Emmett because he'd
come to town and you don't want to
listen to what your parents listen to my
parents would go to the show and like
aunts and uncles and like yeah it was
like more for parents yeah you guys are
lame I was like little kid I don't want
to go like that it's like little kids
and parent where in Kentucky was a
Lexington lesson which is a big city you
know yeah where I'm from
yeah this is a by the way a super
example very clear of the dynamic that
exists within like the country that is a
popular country culture this interviewer
and you'll see like Harry you are so
beautiful I'm working on your my fellow
Oklahoma girl and I wasn't and I was
your age not too long ago now here's a
question my short-sword class I'm not
interrupted like look at that row of
women
yeah why is she the star you know what
is her voice better than the rest of
those girls probably not but yeah you
can tell by the faces which one gets to
be the store right right yeah you sure
can
good point yeah whose is blonde this is
Carrie Underwood here I don't know that
other and then this one right here I
don't know but obviously everybody knows
Amy Moore pride of reality people just
tell me to take off my shorts shorts put
on some normal jeans to get off the hood
of the car okay
I mean that's just yeah that's just
that's like slang I don't know what does
that mean gonna go in these people's
faces oh my gosh no perfect just like my
girls from Oklahoma this is an arena of
people you know I mean and people watch
that as entertainment now if you if you
imagine if from there she's like all
right y'all and now here's wheeler
Walker jeez
you're up my butt I would love that I'm
really trying that's what getting on the
charge is a big deal for me cuz I like
to be like I like knowing that someone
like that manager had to get up at the
next on Monday morning go you're number
yeah well you I'm not in the top 10
who's number 10 and they're like don't
tell her you know yeah fuck you know so
but it is I will say in fairness there's
a lot of kind of big country artists who
are fans and who would piss me off to is
you know they call me or get to my good
to me to their people in the Oh fucking
out because they want to look cool I
look what you're doing so fucking
bad-ass I'm like put on a fucking
t-shirt tweet about it you know don't
keep the other fucking self you know the
cool thing to like say you're a fan of
mine right right but they don't want to
lose it aired they're scared to mention
it that's what the thing is I think that
that fear exists more in country like
other genres of music they wouldn't be
gonna remember too that up and if you
haven't seen I always recommend this
movie this documentary the Dixie Chicks
I forget the title the documentary but
when they got fans from country music
like they're still gone from country
music people hate them still yeah that's
great because I spoke out against the
world the war which by the way my shrink
but yeah yeah but I don't want to get
political but that's what Trump ran on
is what's what they said yeah you know
so what they're saying is what everyone
would cook now agrees with me still
can't come back little things you
brought your guitar would you mind
playing a song yeah okay why don't I
play here's what I want to play because
well I want to preface it by saying
something I don't know if you guys knew
this it's kind of big deal I blew up on
black Twitter two weeks ago you know
what I'm black Twitter yeah sure so I
have a song from the first record called
fuck you bitch
yeah and somebody from the people who
make my records called me up like what's
going on with your first rip because the
new one just came out like why is your
first record selling a bunch and I have
no I looked and they so you blew it you
blew up on black Twitter Wow
and I didn't know what that was it
apparently it's kind of like just the
rest of the world is like shit gets hot
in the like black Instagram and yet like
yeah Twitter first and it makers black
Instagram - well I mean it's it you know
it's not separate but it's within the
yellow K this one dude his name
Daquan or something yeah yeah he's a big
meanie guy he posted my yeah he posted
fuck you bitch and I got like 200
million views Wow and it was that song
from the first record went back up the
church after while my new one was coming
up so I want to I know you ain't
Watchers and all those guys yeah I know
you guys got a lot of black fans
yeah go go for it man because it again
mm-hmm
we're gonna get a real taste right now
oh my god yeah what's up yeah what's
this we we see him okay oh wow that's
gorgeous so I made that for you
Gibson getting out gives me free guitar
nuh-uh Wow you know at what point does
that happen though I think when my first
album within the top ten so a Gibson rep
called and so friend enters me some come
on a Gibson Wow I take a picture of you
with your Gibson his he has his name
that you me and Tom
together yeah yeah it's a crew let me
ask you also before you play it
what so you you know you're in Kentucky
you're in Nashville growing up are you
always playing music then growing up I
was always playing music and then um so
I was always playing and I always and I
was more of a rock guy to be honest yeah
and I got my headphones also let me know
if I'm not close enough to them I know
you're good but for some reason when I
played and sang I could always sing
better I'm not a more natural when I
played country I couldn't I didn't have
a good rock voice yeah and I didn't
really show them like a killer like
guitar I had nothing to offer really for
yeah you know like I love Zeppelin but
there's nothing like I can't be Robert
playing I can't be Jimmy Page but I
could kind of hold mine I could hold my
own with in this country stuff but yeah
they call me they said if you only play
Gibson guitars we'll give you all the
Gibson's you want that Wow
and I go sounds like a fucking because
Gibson it gives it a Martin are the two
best acoustics yes like Mercedes BMW
doesn't matter you already to you
already had some Gibson's though you
were playing it yeah I was actually
playing a Martin at the time and I go I
told them I had a Martin they're just
like keep in your house and don't play
it in public
can we're fine I said they didn't make
me bash it or throw it away yeah you
know stompin yeah I'm really it was
really cool of minimum so you're going
to play me time I get this thing out and
still amazed that they made it amazing
beautiful you're going to play fuck you
bitch yeah just because it's really on
on acoustic okay
a charming tune first house that tells
us now sounds beautiful
yes that's it gives some sound
[Music]
we say we're down active your stuff it's
really over to keep and there's one
thing I'd like to say before you lay
there fucking bitch you broke my heart
look your friends tearing us apart love
your dog hope he never comes home fuck
you bitch
hope you wind up alone
[Music]
now you're going I'm by myself I'm
jerking off pictures on the sill but
before I swap on your face I just
scraped
[Music]
fuck you bitch you broke my heart
look your friends tearing us apart
fuck your dogs who never comes home fuck
you bitch
hope you want up hello
[Music]
word is out
come on well I hope does it for you but
if not darling play thing fucking bitch
you broke my heart
fuck your friend here in this park
look you don't owe ever comes home fuck
you bitch hope you lined up you bitch
hope you want to paint maybe dog great
man I was beautiful thank you for doing
that not okay
I love that great you know what I love
it does harken back to I mean at least
what little I know of country music kind
of the og seems of like I hope your
fucking dog dies you know it's the
heartbreak and drama I appreciate that
because that was kind of my whole point
which is you know you get dumped by a
girl and you know you whether it's your
fault or not let's just assume it was my
fault he when she dumped me like I was
being an asshole you're under your first
dog that off fuck you but you know they
on your head it's not like women are
bitches you know right yeah yeah fuck
you for her ears
it's almost empowering in a weird way
like you have that much control over me
you know like Ryan
fuck you bitch of like because I grew up
you know with country but I also grew up
with you know the hip-hop world of
course without there's like why can't we
talk openly and and uncensored about if
I if I'm feeling that a million other
people got to be feeling it so just
learn so just why why censor it wouldn't
I got asked this we have it because you
mentioned your family multiple times and
we're looking at these posters and you
tracks and everything what do they think
of this music what is your mom think of
well I have owns I'm sure because of awe
had all this fun on pockets I started
doing a podcast and it's we're still
working out too
but it's up on iTunes and shit but I
didn't interview my dad on it and I'm
they don't love it
I did play they came to a couple gig
that came to a couple Nashville gigs and
I'm dude
I'll tell you what's fucking weird a
whole big audience singing along to fuck
you bitch while you're my twat cuz I got
my shades on you know and I could see my
I'm watch all I'm watching is my mum
plugging it down like she can't so she
can't tell ya I'm just watchin my mama
you know she's got a weird I've never
seen her she's never made this face
before or since but the face was is a
weird mix of like I'm proud that you
knows a whole giant room of people
singing along mixed with what I do wrong
to make him sing like shit yeah and
she's watching them go to the merch
booth buying t-shirts and shit so there
I've never seen so much I'm proud and
disgusted at the same time she got both
expressions on her face really well go
mm rant calm and buy some ticket to see
those big mushy Purple's my dad it's
lugging Christina's website yeah but
don't you think that you know once your
mom sees how successful you are that
you'd be like mom this is the house that
fuck you bitch built you know yeah well
build a house yet and that once I buy
them a house may be better but yeah I
will say I'm Yanni if my songs were like
like she gets it you know it'd be
different if I had a hit song with what
you know like women are cunts or just
you know something like that you know it
was like my mom's got a hairy bush or
something you know she understands what
I'm where I'm coming from what actually
digs it yeah because her first heard
reaction is like you got such a pretty
voice and why do you just keep it clean
I mostly yeah well it's what my thing is
and again back to thanking you guys it's
just like now do you I YouTube and
streaming services like why do I keep in
fuck the room why do I need to look a
funny thing is like there's love like
for I'm thinking for like as a parent
too there's levels of language where
it's like oh my son curses you know and
then there's like I'm the pussy King and
like finger up my butt figure out my
butt was definitely the weirdest one
where they just like I know if you want
to hear the origin
that song yeah I was hanging out the
buddy of mine in um in Nashville he
writes kind of hit songs for country
artists yeah and uh he was saying this
one big star who I can't name was just
like he was talking about you know he
young girls on the road kinda what I'm
singing about and he's like you know but
these young girls they don't know that
what they're doing is that sometimes you
just want a finger up your ass and
everyone in the rooms laugh and and I'm
the only one who look I'm like that's a
song you know like a guy who's just like
he can get any girly once but we
shouldn't do it right but he really but
what he wants it's a finger up his fuck
you know and you can never give what you
want like this dude just can only get
off with the finger possess and I was
like again I guess I'm the only guy in
country music who would say that's a
song right there but I think they're
definitely although they what they don't
want to bring it up like do because it's
a but even though I think me it's a
first person song it's about somebody
else but I think my parents are kind of
looking at me like you get off on a
finger up your yeah
gorrister course they're thinking I
don't worried like then when did we when
did we learn start doing that yet me
visualize and you wanna know the truth
which is I even I've heard people say
that they actually enjoy like you know
the soup at the doctor like I fucking
hate like I owe the I'm not yeah yeah no
that'll invest lesser wolf
I know people who say they fucking dug
it it does the rid of the check up I
mean I could see if they could say
they're digging it during sex but I like
the check yeah I want nothing near my
ass so I mean how neither I pride myself
on my honesty but I guess I'm just
proven that that one's not that one's
about somebody else yeah but yeah that's
definitely though but that's another
universal theme I mean I think a lot of
men would would it resonates with I want
to finger my but yeah I think the bigger
idea was again not the specific part of
it but just the idea of just like the
weird shit people are into I wonder how
many people like any of towns you go to
end up there because someone else is
like hey you know this guy likes going
to be in town and I got tickets he's a
singer yeah he's great he's great and
someone just like alright I'll go and
they're just you know they're in the
country and they're just like so see
what this is all about and well the best
part is all that you know the dues with
the backward baseball hat singing
because we end the show with which one
you queer is going to select my dick and
watching a whole crowd of just like do
just like scream that at me yeah it's
like what are they going to do with that
are they going to go home and blow each
other I don't know so yeah I think
that's what's going to happen yeah I
have noticed as the crowds expanding
more we're definitely seeing more women
and more diverse crowd because there was
first especially the first date on that
first tour it was just me it was a
salted sausage dudes which you can't
really put out shit like this and
complain when it's all do well I mean
like honestly as a lady I would be like
this guy is really funny I feel like I
get it I don't know if I would go to a
show cuz I'm like is it going to be a
bunch of dudes are they gonna tear me
apart yeah like I know it's nothing that
you're not like that what you're saying
there's women there so that would I
grate what it is I think is now I think
it's like a liberating it's like I work
all fucking week and then Friday night
I'm gonna get drunk and listen to these
fucking and I'm going to inter music I'm
going to dance and sing about pussy
right and there's salt listen I
mentioned plenty of dicks and yeah right
there's dicks and pussies as we were
saying yeah it's a good time for
actually I forgot that my manager was
going to text and say which shows were
hurting the most I could mention him
here but he never texted back so far his
ass I'm trying to think what it is just
the audience's are so weird too because
we do find this out but our best
audiences for whatever reason the
fucking West Coast really we sell out
all up and down the west coast
sir our West Coast West Coast is grim
yeah I think it's maybe just that you
don't get much country I guess you
possibly or maybe just your seems
resonate you know yeah I'm a they like
it up the ass here a little more hope
that well more honest about it what was
it like by the way how much effort do
you think like what type of thinking
planning and time goes into Johnny Depp
getting ready to go out I know like look
I know you know he's from my hometown
boy really and I knew his cousin and his
my his cousin's life I don't want to say
the guys name buddy I thought death was
a stage name it's not I know it's cousin
his life name is death oh really
yeah I mean isn't this like I mean just
a coordination well he's but he's
dressing like the pirate that he plays
yeah he's been running Jack's fucking
scarves and hang out like what do you
say the other day that he was going to
like shoot the president yeah he made
like some and then he did he issued an
apology the next day
got to watch that shit because they can
now you can't say that shit man you
don't want to be if you're like that
famous if you're like that guy who's
probably he's probably doing drugs all
the time you can't have this secret out
oh yeah fucking watching you all the
time no yeah he was like what was the
last time an actor shot yeah oh yeah
that kind of thing that's actually
really hard to do to accessorize like
that like that like that's theoretically
uh like I've just a shot somebody grab
but that looks fucking posed outright
and that's been this is him at that
thing but I mean bullshit you guys take
all this off to shower
oh it's obsession hour imagine meeting a
girl fucking like if you meet a girl and
just fuck her after this like she's
gonna get her ass fucking bruised we all
in in metal banging against her it's
just like a lot the thing that I that I
would not don't buy about this at all is
that he's just like I just put this on
you know like I just I got up and I got
dressed no you didn't yeah I grabbed my
key and yeah shit to a chain and put it
on my neck
I got my eight scarf sounds and I got
out my 15 wristbands
I think listen I think he's trying to be
Keith Richards I heard you really I
loved him yeah yeah that's that
character the Pyrus character supposed
to be based
oh yeah he's Richard yeah yeah I mean
that's that's probably what it is - and
I think Keith Richards is honestly I
think Keith Richards is like actually
does probably fucking sleep in that shit
and bunch of shit and then just grabs
shit to go like that's piss he's
probably legit yeah you're probably
right it takes so much energy that I'm I
always admire that kind of that level of
accessorizing I'm women like I took a
lot of thought let's date it's not
useful like I swim a lot that I could
take off every fucking tchotchke and the
soccer in the earrings and isn't it
cream I to that he's like you know he's
like the star but he's like a big he's a
kid's star basically you know yeah yeah
I'm hearing you know crazy
oh yeah fucking do but who looks like
that who's like his big hits are all
kids movies now right yeah there's like
Willy Wonka death true um do you wanna
do you want to do one more before we
were bounce do you want me to yeah I'd
love it I do want off the new record
yeah what's it what's it called what's
called summers in Kentucky sometimes
people get a a
a couple radio stations occasionally
seed I'm in the charge and those some of
the tight titles of the songs are clean
yeah and get themselves in a little FCC
trouble by playing oh cause really sure
I go somewhere in Kentucky we can play
that no he didn't on the Billboard
charts and summer stuff is nice that's
really it's a video for this - that was
really helping with and by the way the
one you sang before what was the first
fuck you bitch has a video as a video
yeah that's a good video that one shot
up that one had it like I said black
Twitter must be huge because we had a
huge couple weeks of that that's awesome
so this is summer in Kentucky off a new
album ol wheeler wheeler buy on iTunes
and or Amazon or my website because
we're having trouble like those charts
and not to kiss my own ass but I will
those charts are if means something to
me because it's not a level playing
field my fault but you know all the
other guys are selling out at fucking
Starbucks Walmart bends right
and this giant racks of fucking you know
Chris Stapleton who I love Stapleton but
you know he's got giant racks of his
shit at Walmart that people throw in
their cart yes done fifty thousand a
week it's just Walmart damn and I slept
if I fucked it up I'm singing this
garbage this is summer as you Kentucky
[Music]
sneaking out of my house I was just
sixteen wishing in the dark down by the
tree
let's around till we got cold sleep
genres in Turkey they were hard to be 25
years later our last have changed
meeting girls on the road who are half
my age
another thinking about the creek when
I'm long studies
so music it took a man I miss that flute
used to press pussy up against my mouth
now you've had a couple kid that it's
all stretch down starting to thing we
could figure it out
so next if you wanna inside
[Music]
[Laughter]
if you ever feel like ditching your
Miami red kids hit the road with the
Contra bite there's room for all y'all
not am i lyin
if you start harder labs all over it
her chicken if you got sacked kids
because of age lack shit
[Music]
why I think you see the perfect man I
sure I give up on a pussy any young
shame up bring your flabby ass black now
with Lee a new looking pretty rough I
think my favorite part is that you
mentioned before you saying it says it's
in trouble I should just be a project
program director that's about a
scrambler
from his office that's about as far as I
go with the Syrian gone before it turned
because that's the song cuz I was back
in Kentucky and around Thanksgiving and
I'm a bunch of my friends like let's go
to our high school reunion I'm like I
didn't want to go by more than like
let's just know it was that same old
thing like you know there's a hot girl
from high school and like man she looks
disgusting and then we're like of course
we're all just like look at us we're
fucking worse yeah also like we'd still
fuck her in there she had 12 kids and
you had more marriages or whatever it
was and we're just like you know I I
don't think I could have written that
song without that kind of stretched up
pussy language you know yeah it's it to
different songs like but that definitely
the visual of people just being like
that's on the charge press play
firing no we get what we did for fun was
we sick what you do is on how much you
know about radio but you you do this
where you set you have a big
announcement where you see that the
songs going to radio yeah and you in the
next week in the trades you put out you
know like 50 ads like how many stations
added across the country yeah so we
actually sent that song to radix the
country radio and then took out a big ad
the next week said you know pick up my
pictures is it
thanks to country radio zero ads we got
it add it to zero station Wow very
controversial because that's that week
what they do is they saw on this these
fucking stupid like zero stations
yeah billboard puts the charts you know
you know so-and-so got
you know Garza the g-man got 50 ads
whatever and they actually they usually
don't print it because everyone got zero
they usually don't print zero but they
put in me
we were walking junior summers in
Kentucky zero Wow let's take bad that's
their loss because I really think your
song does like you say reflect reality I
mean it's get soggy and kids almost like
like done it 2017 what can you say dirty
work I mean I understand that so like
it's a law but I mean silly
why can't you fucking curse at me I see
you at the SNL like kind of skirting
around it you know yeah man I saw
Chappelle doing some crazy shit on there
yeah why can't you just say pussy it's
not who cares and here's what I
understand is and what I said before is
like I heard pussy on Meet the Press
I heard Trump saying oh yeah like that
clear right it's like so if I said it in
like a mean way it would worked my gas
if yeah if it's if it's a pejorative way
right looks funny like women I've seen
it like in a meme or something but it's
still kind of crazy that did not limit
when they talked about that that pussy
audio in that clip to like the one guy
the one got one of the guys in this
conversation got fired right and the
other guy's president of the United the
guy that actually said it it's president
but we're still going to act like it's
something that we nobody can say you're
here you know yeah exactly it's like
some bad you could I mean I assumed I
just assumed like everyone else it was a
you bet you can't say grab bud and I
just was always like I'm the smartest
fucking guy I'm like I'm so smart like
you you grab you bragged about grabbing
people about the pussy with a microphone
on yeah right yeah like come on man like
not giving a game this smart that was a
great song that was awesome was really
funny
yeah well listen to to the listeners
listen to the album version because this
producer did an amazing job on that one
and only we'll check it out look get the
album is called Oh wheeler wheeler
Walker jr. and go see him live in
concert go to wheeler Walker jr. calm
and also while you're at it pick up the
old one the first one a redneck shit
well I can't thank you guys enough
because like I said it's been this
podcast world that's really keeping me
alive well there's no one
else that'll have me they're going to
support you for Sherman and enough but
it's this whole new it's really it's
almost like underground radio in a way
society it is a whole new thing which
people are under estimating you know
like they've been under estimating it
but they're starting to come I think so
but like like I said I had a tough
you're not going to get any other top 10
country artists stopping by here I don't
know yeah I didn't let your first but
it's like they should yeah they should
why wouldn't they you know well for
smart you're you're a trailblazer your
unique your outcast and I think that's
why people appreciate your work thank
you I hope it keeps going because here's
a yeah oh it's going I got to make this
money back no you're going to check it
out check out thank you guys for as
always for listening to our palm cast
okay and here's a slicker by our Pat's
on the way out of here again thank you
to our guest wheeler Walker danger being
here that's great this is nice a great
palm cast thank you very much
[Music]
why you gay don't be me we're for me to
be okay would see me emitting a beauty
[Music]
turn turn turn turn turn turn turn turn
come
[Music]
maybe a seed cake you get to the onion
spell
Oh
[Music]
you bracket
I will lick your ass
[Music]
Oh